eateat up but it's now Geo Tita who's
your least favorite cast member on the
show if they come back with me as the
answer don't tell me I would actually
say myself
I'm the worst acts I'm game of Thrones
and I'm proud of it
life is boring who's got the best
costume I think sir these costumes of
the bass wore this red dress I think in
season one that was like a little boat
neck and it was incredible which cast
member is the most annoying okay she
said that absent I would say KITT do you
have any faith in me at all we saw a
lion do you like the least you're
getting the dirt that's why we're asking
the questions because you're gonna get
some dirt
oh that's so oh they just want beerus to
like turn around and like you know kill
someone to their face this is a mistake
what was your most memorable onset meal
why not
ha I think I once brought in my own
protein bar that was no offense that
wasn't the best meal I've ever had on
the set of Game of Thrones
[Applause]
[Music]